there's proposals that are going on now
and you know just so people know this
end zone celebrations tutorial you know
all this stuff has to be agreed upon now
that what the NFL is doing and then what
are they going to do with kickoffs and
replay so just to keep you up to speed
on it Mike's here to separate fact from
fiction hear you talk to Dean Blandino
the head of officials today what's the
big big take away from that well I
wanted to get more clarification about
how this new replay process is going to
work down because they're getting rid of
the sideline voting booths are trying to
streamline and make it more efficient
they're going to take a tablet out to
the referee which is a great bonus for
Microsoft and its product placement cuz
that bright blue tablets going to be in
the hands of the referee for every
replay review but the league office is
now going to have final say previously
it was the referee with final say with
the league office talking to him and
giving him guidance and making sure that
he applies the right standard because a
lot of time the referees look at that
and they supply their own judgment
instead of sticking to the 50 drunks in
a bar indisputable visual evidence
standard now someone in the legal office
is going to have final say Dean Blandino
is there with two other people on a game
day because we know what happens at 1pm
Eastern 10 games kickoff everything is
going on you may have multiple reviews
at the same time but the league off is
going to have final say Blandino is
going to be involved in as many of them
as he can and his job is going to be to
make that decision based on the standard
indisputable visual evidence whether or
not the ruling on the field gets
overturned the goal is to get it done
more quickly and ensure consistency
because the referees have different
views as to what is and isn't something
that should be overturned with the same
guy doing it all the time the idea is
there always going to make the right
decision when it's time to do a replay
review I saw where a Dan Snyder of
Washington Redskins Fame said that how
about we do something with the kickoff
where if you put it through the uprights
then the opposition has the ball at the
20 and if you don't make it through the
uprights it goes out to the 25 how's
this being received well I look anytime
it's a team proposal that means that for
whatever reason there wasn't enough
people on the competition committee to
get behind it and make it a big deal so
and and it's a weird combination because
you got the competition committee Dan
that spends weeks studying these
potential changes consults with the
Union consults with the GM subcommittee
coaches subcommittee may come up with
their proposals but then any team can
propose anything they want as long as
they reduce it to writing and submit it
before the deadline so this thing seems
a little gimmicky I like the idea of
creating an incentive to bang it out of
the end zone if the goal is to have
fewer kickoff returns it makes sense if
you miss it but it still goes out it's
once you were kickoff return so I I
could see where it would have some
appeal I just feel like there's a line
that they don't want to cross where
things seem a little bit too hokey and a
little bit too goofy but I like the
creativity anytime somebody brings
something the table that's different
than what we're used to it's at least
worth talking about it but I'd be
surprised if 24 owners get behind it
what if we gave you a point if you made
it through the uprights that was an idea
that's been floated by I think Justin
Tucker's a big on that because he could
probably bang every kick that he tries
through the uprights but thatthat's
along the same lines it's something that
would be a fundamental change and it
does feel a little gimmicky but it will
give you a reason to stick around and
watch the kickoff because right now most
of the kickoffs are hey it goes deep
into the endzone guy takes a knee or
goes out of the end zone if you can put
it through there and you get a point for
your team then that definitely is
something that would hold people's
attention but wouldn't that be weird to
see a game get tied late with five
seconds left and the game comes down to
overtime or Justin Tucker kicking it
through the uprights from I love a
5-yard line I don't think I like that oh
I love the drama attached to that now
you mentioned over time and I couldn't
follow you you know I was listening to
your show and I couldn't follow exactly
what you were saying about your new
overtime rules so explain it okay and
let me give you a real example to bring
it to life Steelers Bengals at Heinz
Field the game's tied and the regulation
period is over so what do you do it over
time my my vision for this is to get
away from all back and forth
sudden-death usual construct borrow from
soccer and hockey put the Steelers
offense in the bengals defense at one
end of the field the bengals offense in
the steelers d
sense at the other end of the field and
go back and forth two-point conversions
like a hockey or soccer shootout do
three times each with like a tight time
frame so it's got kind of a fast-paced
bang bang feel to it 20 25 seconds
between snaps each team does three that
six total snaps for overtime if the game
is still tied then you just go one at a
time like they do in a hockey or a
soccer shootout once they've finished
that basic shootout frame and until
somebody's ahead and the game is over so
it could be six snaps eight snaps 10
snaps that they're concerned about
player health and safety and that's why
they're talking about shrinking over
time from 15 minutes to ten minutes to
get these games over with that's a way
to get it over with I think it would be
compelling I think it would be must-see
TV could you imagine a cowboys Packers
game on a Sunday night going to overtime
and having that happen to resolve it so
I a little there's a fine line between
outside the box and crazy but I I don't
like the overtime rule I don't like I
mean I know it's not sudden death
anymore but you were going to have a lot
more ties if they shrink it to 10
minutes because the team that receives a
kickoff is going to get a field goal
then the other team goes down and gets a
field goal and there is enough time left
to break the tie we better get used to
ties if they do shrink this to 10
minutes about making any other changes
these Mike Florio profootballtalk.com
all right a couple of quick items here
Raiders moving ahead are they going to
play at UNLV s a stadium for a year
they're going back to oakland for this
year and then moving ahead to maybe UNLV
for a year before the stadium is built
they've got a lease in Oakland and that
lets them play their 2017 and 2018 if
they want to year to year lease now the
question is one with their new stadium
in Las Vegas be ready and what would you
do if you get to 2019 I mean they can
opt out 2018 and play in las vegas or
they could stay in oakland for 2018 and
then 2019 they'd have to figure out what
to do and look this Marshawn Lynch stuff
has died down over the last week I still
think it's on the table and I think from
the Oakland Raiders perspective it's
brilliant to possibly bring him in if
they get approval to move to Las Vegas
and they're going to be in oakland for
another year or two you bring an Oakland
native in and that helps hold the fan
base together for those last couple of
lame duck seasons
it's going to be weird to have a team
have multiple years in a stadium is
about the move away from no but where's
his leave Adrian Peterson well boy I can
only imagine what he's going through now
after making 16 17 million last year due
to make 18 million this year and I think
whatever's out there for him as a
fraction of what he's used to making I
think teams are playing it smartly he
needs to come to grips with the fact
that the money isn't going to be there
he needs to see what Eddie Lacy signs
for he needs to see what some of these
other guys signed for before he realizes
you know what I'm not going to get what
I'm used to and he may decide to just
wait and in that his best play he
doesn't like the offseason program he
told me last year that the grind of the
offseason program is one of the reasons
why he'd possibly retire sooner than he
otherwise would and you wait for
somebody to get injured fun facts get
injured all the time you get a
high-profile running back on a
successful team blows out in the in
training camp preseason
september-october here comes Adrian
Peterson to the rescue that may be his
best move and it definitely would give
him more leverage if he's operating from
that position where they need me because
they've lost their starting running back
Colin Kaepernick is none employed now
because why well look I I think that I
think that his national anthem protest
from last year is a big part of this if
he was Tom Brady he would have a job you
know any time that you create a
distraction and coaches don't like to
stretch and they don't like anybody
who's different they want these guys to
all be robots I got enough to deal with
with 53 guys in the locker room you
start bringing in extra issues it makes
it harder to manage your team not that
it's right or wrong that's just the way
it is if you're a great player they'll
find a way to deal with it if your
marginal they're going to find a way to
not deal with it and I think the problem
is they're 80 coaches out there that
think Colin Kaepernick could help their
team I bet if you attach you Jackson to
a lie detector test he'd say yes he's by
far the best option we're going to have
this year in Cleveland but you have to
wonder higher up in the organization
what are the owners tank are they afraid
fans are going to revolt now look Browns
fans have been suffering through a lot
of bad football for the last generation
I don't think they're going
to flee the team if they signed colin
kaepernick but it just may be basic
political ideology differences where
owners don't want this guy around
because they think you should stand for
the flag and they think that what he did
was wrong and simply because he plans to
stand this year isn't enough to reset
the clock to zero so it has to be a
factor look at some of the guys getting
job it has to be a factor 16 touchdown
passes and four interceptions last year
for a team that otherwise was crap how
do you not at least bring him in talk to
him let him run let him throw and then
make a decision the fact that it's been
crickets for the last 16 days I think
allows us to come to the conclusion that
something fishy's going on any traction
with this Johnny Manziel meeting with
Sean Payton in the sink I think you got
to read the tweets carefully from Ian
Rapoport I it feels like it's an effort
by someone maybe the agent this is one
of the benefits of having an agent
because agent starts working the media
to breathe life into something and make
something seem more than maybe it is
it's one thing for Sean Payton to take
an interest in Johnny Manziel it's
another thing for Sean Payton to be
interested in hiring Johnny Manziel so
you know again you have an agent he
starts working the media these things
start bubbling up and maybe somebody
else takes a closer look at him and
that's really all the agent can do at
this point we've seen what happened in
2014 2015 you know every time he
convinces somebody he's got his act
together it all falls apart again and I
can't think of a team out there that
wants to be the team that becomes fooled
the latest time by a guy who says all
the right things and then shows up and
never does any of the right things
necessary to be successful how long is
Tony Romo going to still be a company
well this is the key Dan everybody's
about Arizona this weekend for the
league meetings and I think Jerry Jones
realized a few weeks ago that let's just
play this out and it's one thing for Bob
McNair to be sitting in his office in
Houston and Jerry Jones to be in his
office and both guys staring at the
phone not wanting to be the guy who
picks up the phone and makes the first
phone call on a possible trade but when
they're rubbing elbows and hanging out
at meetings and they're around each
other it can come up more naturally and
I think Jones is hoping that somehow
some way just through being in the same
place for three or four days in Arizona
is going to be a trap how could just
something come up with some kind of
conditional draft pick for 2018 based
upon how many snaps he takes how
successful the team is you look at what
he can do if he's healthy he's worth
something and I think that's why Jerry
Jones initially decided to let him go
but then realized you know I can maybe
just wait a while and get something for
him but if nothing happens between now
and Wednesday you know I just think it's
a matter of time before they cut him
loose the last item how do you think it
plays out with the Patriots going to the
White House I think the over/under I
talked about this earlier i put the
over-under at eleven of guys who aren't
going to go and that's for all reasons
whether it's scheduling conflict I don't
feel like going political reasons
whatever I got it 11 i think we're
already at six but it's earlier than
usual too but I got it 11 and we'll see
how that plays out it's coming up in
like three and a half weeks I'm going
against brady you'll be there bella
check will be there and robert kraft
will be there well if they wouldn't be
boycotting for political reasons let's
just say that yes Mike have a great
weekend thanks for joining us all right
buddy Mike Florio profootballtalk.com
the Dan Patrick show weekday morning on
audience